there are various theorems for various
definitions but in the stock I'll be
talking about probably the most common
notion
so let me Define it so I'll be very
general we have a
probability Space X with measure mu on
it and we consider F from X to the N to
zero one so it's a Boolean function on
this product space then
so I want to define the influence of the
jth variable on F so what I'm going to
do is I'll sample first X1 to xn so each
according to this probability space so
each one will be independently drawn
using using the measure mu and I make
another sample for XJ so I redraw
XJ let's call it YJ so y j is again
another independent random variable
chosen according chosen according to
Major mu and I look at the probability
that F of this the first set of
variables is not
the same as f after I resampled the jth
variable
okay so there's a chance that for
example when this is a discrete space
that these two actually are the same so
that will also let's considering this
definition now the main thing I'm
interested is the total influence which
is the sum of all these influences so
for for every variable I look at the
influence of that variable and F and add
them up
so let's look at an example to just uh
get comfortable with the depression so
the most
common setting is you have just a
uniform distribution and zero and one so
each variable is zero with probability
half and one with probability of an
unbiased coin basically now I have a
function from 0 1 to the N to zero one
let's look at particular function which
is a parity so just count the number of
ones and see if it's even or out and
then according to that we are zero or
one for the back in this case uh what is
the influence object variable so I want
F of X1 to x j and be different from
this so
these two things should be should not be
the same
so that's exactly the same and this
probability which is the same as so
if I flip the jth variable the value of
f will flip will change so what is the
probability that that value is changed
when I resample it it's just the
probability that XJ is not equal to y j
which is half so it's a bit uh so
there's another way of defining
influences in this setting which is more
common which is just you change the
variable but because I'm working on
General spaces it's more convenient to
look at it this way just resample it so
we'll get half so the total influence
will be n half which is very large so
the maximum you get is n
in general
uh for this yeah in zero one to the end
case
well actually yeah in general but this
is a maximum detection
okay now uh let's look at another
example now let's uh let's look at the
Bernoulli random variable but now with a
huge bias so the tb1 Over N so it
probably one over n we're gonna
we get one and with probability one
minus that we get zero now let's
consider any arbitrary function so now f
is from 0 1 to the N but endowed with
this mu P to the m basically to zero one
now what is the influence object
variable so I want this to be different
and that is bounded by the probability
that extra is XJ is not the same as YJ
but this happens with very tiny
probability because with a very very
large probability will always get will
get zero for both of them so this is
going to be 2p times 1 minus p and which
is roughly around 1 over n so the total
influence is very small in this case too
for any function so on this particular
probability space any function has very
small total influence
now the main question I'm interested in
is that what can we say about the
structure functions which have
a small total influence and small means
uh just constant total influence and as
we saw in the pre uh
okay yes
so the as we saw in the previous
data
yeah
new answer to it
okay
all right so as we saw in the previous
slide for some probability spaces we
might get all functions but for others
we'll get more simpler structure but I
want a very general answer
now some background about this problem
is that in general
um Russo is probably the first to study
these type of questions in in a
systematic way there are Works about
thresholds and so before work of Russo
but they're more specific to particular
functions and then an important result
in this direction is the is the famous
inequality of KKL inequality is to
conquerline lineal which considers the
uniform measure on zero one to the n and
there are extensions to this p-bias
setting by Telegram and uh it would
basically he looked at this proof of KKL
and realized that it gives actually a
structural theorem for for functions
from zero one to the N to zero one with
small total influences with the uniform
measure so this case is basically like
fairly understood using the fairly well
understood using the ethereum
oh no no yeah
okay
there's some controversy
yeah
this is your paper in community
and then later he looked at this p-bias
case which is
way more complicated and he found the
complete characterization of graph
properties with the settings so I'll
explain later what does graph property
means in the setting basically grab
properties we can think of graphs as
functions and then you can
look at this at the training graph and
then this these functions are really
important there and he found the
complete characterization of that which
which is a very complicated and nice
proof
and from that uh he answered some very
interesting and important questions that
for example three sets recolorability
this car and the properties it's a bit
sharp thresholds which I'm gonna explain
later and Borgen uh an appendix to paper
Fritos paper uh partially extended this
to generals I think so functions from X
to the N to zero one which is the
setting I'm interested and what I want
to do is to extend uh fruit cut CRM to
this general setting fully so let me
talk about one of the important
applications of
or motivation of the studying these
functions and that's a phase transition
so we all are familiar with this airdush
rainy
random graph so you have n vertices on
each edges around independently
with probability p
so for every Edge we basically uh we
flip a biased coin and decide to put it
there or not with probability p
now uh
so in this original paper where the
training they observed that many
fundamental graph properties they
exhibit this interesting threshold
phenomena where when p is zero so we are
interested in using margin properties so
when P0 the graph which is the empty
graph doesn't have the property and P1
the graph has the property so if you
look at this graph which corresponds to
what is the probability that the graph
has the property usually you see this
kind of quick jump from close to zero to
close to one and this is like where the
connectivity it happens very close to
zero but you have a sudden jump
and the main
so when this threshold happens which
actually happens for every monotone
property so the question is how sharp is
the threshold so how sharp is this
transition
and I'm not going to be very formal here
but basically it means that what is this
uh how short is this interval interval
where we jump from close to zero to
close to one compared to the critical
value which is where the property
satisfied with probability have so this
is a ratio between this interval and
that
so connectivity for example exhibits a
sharp threshold meaning that this
interval is very short compared to
critical probability but say the
probability of containing a triangle for
a graph or uh is not doesn't exist a
sharp threshold there is a more gradual
increase in the property in the
probability
so those kind of properties like
connectivity or containing a triangle
it's possible to analyze actually and
find the critical value what is and the
uh size of that transition interval but
when you look at something more
complicated for example satisfiability
of three sets or three color lithium
graph it's very hard to analyze that
probability and find the actual curve so
one needs to to in order to prove or
understand the existence of sharp
threshold one has to take a different
approach
and interestingly there is a very
general approach it's not it's uh you
don't really have to work with the
property in in a very detailed way so
the first the first observation is that
which is basically the definition of
this sharp threshold is that
um
if if you don't see a sharp threshold so
this increases very gradual
but then at some point the derivative
should be low so if you take the
derivative of this curve it should be
comparable to uh one over the critical
probability this should be PC
um so that's if that happens to say that
there's a course threshold
and so the
existence of a course threshold or shop
threshold is equivalent to answering
this question for which functions on
this P bias distribution this derivative
is the same order as one over a critical
probability
and there is a Lemma which relates that
to influences so there's lamadu to Russo
and margulis independently which says
that this probability distributive is
exactly of the same order as the total
influence divided by P so the course
threshold basically means constant total
influence in this setting so that's why
we are interested in this pbias setting
what are the functions which
small total influences or constant total
influences
and another more General motivation is
that
when you usually when you have a nice
description for for a function you say
having a slow depth decision tree or
some other
um
way of evaluating it you can analyze the
influences and usually you get low
influences yes
no it's uh
yeah
for some people some p in the critical
range
so that critical property is not that
important that it's exactly have
anything which is far from a zero and
from one pounded away from zero and one
works so something between Epsilon and
one
what should be
it shouldn't matter because the
derivative will be essentially zero not
really yeah
I mean you can have small jumps there
but but people don't I mean at least for
like it's not very common to analyze
that range it's mostly okay
it's usually you take one p and which is
comparable to critical probability and
then analyze what is this sequence
okay so
um
so I mean this is another motivation to
say these functions with small total
influences so let me go and look at now
examples of functions with smarter than
influences so uh a very
uh easy set of functions which you can
easily see that they have this property
at home test so these are functions
where they depend on a small set of
variables so
uh so there's a small set of variables
say k where you think of K as some
constant and you know that your function
only looks at these particular variables
so f of x is G of x i 1 to x i k for
some particular G
and
now every variable outside Hunter also
this small set of variables
has influenced zero because if it
doesn't look at those variables so the
total influence is at most k
so if K is a constant we get a function
with small total influence so Hunters
are a set of functions which we have the
property that we are interested in
so this gives us kind of a direct
theorem that if your function is a
hundred and the total influences
constant and frequency result which was
uh basically looking at kkl's proof and
says that for the uniform measure on 0 1
if your function has small total
influence then it's close to a hunter so
it's kind of an inverse theorem for this
direction so so it gives us the
understanding of this case if you are a
hunter you have constant total influence
if you have constant total influence you
are close to it
so this is a more precise formulation so
for any Epsilon you get a hunter which
has dependence on Epsilon the number of
variables we have and those functions
and Epsilon controls your error that's
how close are you to Hunter
and you can easily extend the proof to
um
P bias measure where where p is a
constant just because you get some
dependency NP but this
completely falls apart when you look at
small piece where p is of disorder n to
the minus some constant in this range
the proof doesn't tell you anything it
says it's a n Junta which means just a
certain function
and this is the range we are interested
for or people are interested for the
threshold application most most
interesting properties like being three
colorable
or three sets and satisfiability they
are in this range where p is very very
small
so it doesn't tell us anything for this
kind of problems so connectivity which
is logging over n
so uh
uh let's look at now another set of
functions which have this structure a
more General thing which I call them
pseudonym test
so let me give you the definition is a
bit involved
now we have
a collection of constraints or functions
same thing which are indexed by subsets
of n so for every subset of n s a health
function Js from X to the N to 0 1 which
depends only on coordinates in s so I
can think of it as a constraint over
variables indexed by elements of s
all right so one think of one as being
satisfied the constrained and satisfied
and zero it doesn't satisfy and it only
looks at those variables
so it only depends on coordinates in s
JS now
let's for a particular X now
let's call
let's define the set of active
coordinates of x to be the variables
which are in some satisfied constraint
so it's the union of all those S such
that the corresponding constraint is
satisfied JS is equal to 1 for this x so
you look at all these satisfied
constraints each one of them has some
variables and look at all those
variables it gives us some subset of
coordinates of x
let's look at an example so let's look
at the zero one case and my constraints
are the following uh
they're only on these sets consequent
elements I and I plus one and the
constraint is set the corresponding
constraint is satisfied if both of those
variables are one
now if you look at this particular X say
0 1 1 1 0 1 1 0 0. you see these two
variables they satisfy some constraint
they are both one
and their consequence so these two
they're underlined and then these other
two this that's why another constraint
again there are two consequent
coordinates which are both ones so I
overline them then there's these two
also satisfied so these five coordinates
s2s3 and S6 are satisfied these five
coordinates are my active set of
coordinates okay so each of them is in
some satisfied constraint
um
yes I want to change something here
yeah there's a one it's not something
yeah but uh it's not that all the ones
are gonna be satisfied so if I I can
change some variables and still get the
same set of active coordinates so if I
change this zero to one I'll have the
same set of active coordinates
so we'll see later that I want to
partition my space so that these two
elements will be the same in the same
atom because they have the same set of
active coordinates and the values in
those set of active coordinates are the
same so these five ones are the same in
both of them and the same in the same
place
so that's uh okay already have it here
so I'll partition my whole Space using
this um
and this protocol that X and Y are in
the same part if and only they have the
same set of active coordinates and the
Restriction to those active coordinates
are the same
so this gives me a partition of the
whole Space X to the end now this is uh
now I can give you the definition of a
student Hunter
so a function is called
a case to the hunter if I can find such
a set of constraints such that
um f is first of all measure it's
measurable with respect to this
partition so f is constant on all every
atom so it can't have different values
in these two or these two which are in
the same atoms and the other constraint
is that this k thing is that if I pick a
random X using my
probability distribution then the number
of active coordinates
in average is small it's bounded bounded
by K okay so I don't want to have many
active coordinates in average and also I
want to be partition measurable with
this to this partition
Okay so
so another thing is that this is a
generalization of a K Hunter K Hunters
are also case to the hunter can easily
see by just putting the constraints on
those K variables which matter in the
hometown
and so another observation is that now
let's look at X and Y which differ only
on one coordinate which is the case we
are interested when we look at the
influences
then
so let's just look at this for example
this is one this is zero here
then if J in this coordinate is not
active in any of X or Y
then X and Y are in the same cells right
because
they're the same on the active
coordinates and
and they had the same active coordinates
and this particular one where they
differ is not in the active coordinate
so what does this tell us it tells us
that
so I'm going to use the subdivision show
that if my function is the case to the
hunter then the total influence is bound
by 2K it can't be large so let's see why
so this is just the definition of the J
influence now because of the previous
observation I know that if f f is
measurable with respect to this
partition the sigma algebra so if f is
not the same for these two elements it
means that J should have been active in
at least one of these two
set up at least in one of these two
points this and the change one here
and this is just I can use the Union
band the probability that J is active in
this one plus the probability that J is
active in this one which is the same
because these are independent so this is
just twice the probability that J is
active for a random X which is
um if I add up over all J it's just the
expected number of active coordinates so
it will be bound to the bar by 2K so we
showed that case to the hunters have the
property that we want they are they have
bounded total influences
now
um so this is what we showed
and what speed got showed is that our
frequency serum tells us that we have an
inverse theorem for graph properties
that if your function corresponds to a
graph property
and it has small total influence for
this in this GMP setting then f is
essentially a sudo Hunter you can
approximate it by
by a function which is a pseudonym
definition that I gave you but the the
restrictions of this theorem is that
first of all it's about graph properties
and it heavily uses this symmetries of
graph properties that the graph property
is invariant on the rotation of vertices
so
I think like the paper has 14 lemmas and
each one of them uses this symmetry
really like as I was trying to
generalize it every time that I was
generalizing a Lemma saying okay I'm
probably done and then the next level
again there was the same problem with
symmetries and still actually the what
particular shows is a bit more than what
I'm gonna show for the for the general
setting so there is one level of which I
couldn't generalize uh and the other
thing is that it's only applicable to P
bias settings so it's really so describe
things you have only zero one cases for
every Edge so that's another restriction
and uh what's Bogan as I said
and the beginning of the talk extend
this partially to this general setting
but we're against theorem is really
different from frequencyorem it doesn't
come with a direct theorem so as we saw
with the Sudan situation if a
functioning student it has small total
influence and quick gas theorem says
that if a graph property has small total
influence then it's closer to the hunter
but burgundy serum just gives some
some weak structure inside the function
so it doesn't give us something Global
that's it's close to some structure
function
so what I showed is that if the function
is has a small total influence then it's
essentially a pseudo Hunter and more
precisely these are the dependencies for
every Epsilon
in my pseudohonta is parameter K that we
saw is going to be exponential and
Epsilon inverse Cube and total influence
Q so there is probably room to improve
here too
for actually zero one so for Boolean
case I can get quadratic here but this
project in general
and okay so that's the theorem so I'm
going to talk a bit about the proof it's
the proof is very combinatorial in some
sense and has many many steps so I can't
really give you a high level intuition
but I'll mention some of the ideas in
the proof so uh it's the first CRM or
KKL theorem use free analysis and here
in this general setting we use something
similar the previous decomposition which
so that with the compose function our
function f to these functions F sub s
which are indexed by subsystem
1 to n
and so they have this property similar
to characters that the fs only depends
on coordinates in s and the other
property is that
um
they have if you integrate over just x i
variable for any ion as then you get
zero so fix all the other variables just
integrate over any override variable
then you get zero and from this you get
that these are pairwise orthogonal so
it's an orthogonal decomposition
um
and you get something like get passable
as an equality that the electron Norm is
autonom square is the sum of L to Norm
squared these functions and also the
this decomposition is influencers are
very nice when you look at such a
decomposition you get a very nice
formula it's just the you look at the
sum but only for the sets s that contain
I that gives us the influence that I
influence
now okay so that's the decomposition so
we're gonna the first step is
what the general step is that we
approximate f with a simpler function G
in L2 norm and then show that Define
this constraints which gonna give us the
pseudo Honda definition and show that
then G is close to
its projection to this Sigma algebra so
it's conditional expectation with
respect to this partition so this is
small then we'll be done f is close to g
g is close to this function which is
measurable with respect to this
partition and then because f is Boolean
you can round this thing to it it's just
the usual thing approach of doing this
so the first step which comes from the
S3 KKL paper or probably even before
that is so you look at this
decomposition and because the total
influence is small
um I'm not going to go into detail
because this is just something from KKL
is that you can get rid of the high
frequencies so
uh
this thing will be small if you look at
this L2 Square sum for sets s which are
larger than K this will be bounded by
total influence but over K so if you
take K large enough this is a constant
you can get rid of all these high
frequencies without losing much in the
electronome so that will so f is
approximately the sum where we only look
at the small sets s
so this is say our function G now the
second thing is which is a very
important ingredient in the proof is
bogan's theorem which was which is the
main thing in boogers an inequality
which we showed is that when the total
influence is small we'll have the
following so by pass the wall L2 Norm of
f squared is the sum of L2 Norm squares
of these fs's right so this is just the
parcel but now he said he showed that
we can restrict these integrals only to
points where FS is larger than some
constant so FS ranges from 0 to 1 and
actually most of the time is very small
when P the smallest very close to zero
and show that the part which contributes
here are only the ones where actually FS
is huge which is larger than some
constant
there will be this approximation will
depend on Epsilon 1 and total influence
um
okay and then
so how does so this gives us some idea
how should we Define our constraints the
constraint JS is defined as one if FS of
the point is larger than this Epsilon so
we want to look at only two for this set
of s only look at the part where
actually this function FS that we had is
large where it should matter in this sum
yes
uh
it doesn't depend on that
independent yeah just depends on total
influence
um
foreign
so it uses something similar to
hypercontractivity which holds for every
probability space
with no dependency on PR
ank Okay so
um
so now when FS of X is large then the
set s is activated the constraint is
satisfied
then X will be
this will show and we know that FS only
depends on coordinates in s so this says
that for such an S so such values of x f
s will be equal to
this expected value because X will be
so these functions of the real constant
on those things
so
by borgen's inequality which I have here
is this guy is very close to zero the
sum of these averages of FS minus this
conditional expectation
but the problem is so we are not done
here because
we want to look at this thing so we want
to say f is close to conditional
expectation of f with respect to this
partition which means that we're
interested in the sum of f s minus these
things
but these are not orthogonal if they
were orthogonal they would be done at
this point because we could write this
we could just take out this sum from
this average and then we would get this
which is zero so we wouldn't lose much
but because these are not orthogonal we
are not done and
uh another thing is that with this
definition this is a pseudo Honda which
I didn't mention before it's very simple
to see that so this the number of active
coordinates will be a constant
um
well it's really that's three line proof
I'm not going to go over it don't have
enough time
and the main difficulty is bounding the
error so remember that we first
approximated it with low frequencies so
we got rid of all this hyper constants
we will only dealing with small values
of s and then we want to show that this
G is close to its expected value with
respect to this uh
Sigma algebra now this expected value I
can write it as this sum because it's
going to it's expectationless linear
so I have this now
it's very hard to analyze this because
FJ this active coordinates depends
on all coordinates so you can just flip
one coordinate somewhere and then
suddenly you get completely different
set of coordinates which because it just
made some other constraints being
satisfied so
this this guy here expectation of FS
with respect to this partition depends
on all coordinates and not on S
so the good thing was about good thing
about this Welsh partitioners watch
Fourier partition was that this FSS they
depend only on us they were very low
column in terms of the coordinates but
once you take this conditional
expectation you lose this property
suddenly when you tell you're averaging
this over some atoms which depend on all
coordinates which makes analyzing this
very difficult so what we do here is
that we Define some auxiliary
partitions or Sigma algebras F's indexed
by this sets s
which are defined the following way we
activate some coordinate if we're sure
that it's activated by just looking at
some x sub s so for example in this set
if you look at this point with the
constraints that I had before the
consequent ones
I'm not going to activate this one
because by just looking at these four
coordinates I'm not sure if this is
going to be activated this might be zero
outside the sets so the only ones which
I'm sure are these two they're already
satisfied so they're activated
okay so this
this is a coarser sigma algebra than FJ
and has this nice property that it only
depends on coordinates in s
so these are the two interesting
properties that it has
and because it's coarser I know that
I can bound
this thing which I'm interested with
uh
taking this conditional expectation with
coarser Sigma algebra so the function I
have in this sum is measurable with
respect to FJ and I know that if I want
to approximate the best thing I can do
is to just take the conditional
expectation with respect to that
partition so I get this inequality now
this this is much easier to handle
because these things are depend on the
uncoordination S for example
I'll get that these These are orthogonal
when there's no intersection between S1
and S2
so behave totally independently
so uh so I'm I'll be only interested in
cases where there is some intersection
this intersection is not zero so we can
get something like this and that just
I don't expect you to really follow this
calculations
so you get something like this we know
that this is small by burgundy
inequality it remains to deal with these
cases where there is intersection
and then you look at take some T and
then look at what happens when the
intersection is exactly T and then you
basically so what I told you as the part
partition or this constraints was just a
kind of a toy version of it or very
extremely simplified version of it so
use I the way I found the proof I
started with that then it that doesn't
work so I keep refining the partition to
get rid of all these error terms that
they were actually they could actually
accumulate so in the actual proof the
this functions JS are very complicated
so you have a question so
we also required the number of fjs the
number of constraint could be of one no
no it's just the expected number of
activated coordinates it sounds
fantastic
so in the actual proof
this is JS it's defined in the very
complicated ways pretty messy so I have
this functions as which are very similar
to I had before just look at the large
values of FS then you look to sum up
over various T's and then you get these
and then you maximize it or something so
this is really like and it was just you
start from this and then keep trying to
make it to something which works and it
was really took a long time to find the
right formulation for trade but still
it's easy to see that this will give it
to the hunter
um
and another thing which was very not
actually I hadn't seen it anywhere else
was that just this FS didn't I couldn't
analyze it using this and I had to
approximate them with some other
functions JS which had some nice
properties so they were very similar to
FS but and they were good approximations
for them but also they had small L1
7 so the original FS doesn't have this
property so that some of the l1s can be
very large
but I had to somehow smooth them to get
this other extra property so um
to finish the tag
in the threshold examples we are really
so when you look at threshold you're
interested in increasing functions you
want the probability of satisfaction go
up as you increase the value of P so you
need your property to be increasing
so something which follows from
fridger's theorem is that if you have a
increase in graph property and it has
coarse threshold or equality small total
influence then you can find a small set
of coordinates such that if you set them
to one or if you put those edges there
then the probability that your function
satisfies the probability will go as
close as you want to one for example if
your property is being containing a
triangle actually you can make it one by
just implanting a triangle there right
just setting three edges but also if
your property is say being non bipartite
um that's again you can same thing yeah
same triangle works but you can cook up
examples where you can just make you
can't really get one with putting uh
just small set of edges but you can make
it as close as you want to want
and uh what we're getting shot this so
This is actually what we can show is
that you can
you can move it a little bit so you can
set these coordinates to one such that
you boost the expected value by a bit by
some Delta which is a constant but his
proof doesn't imply that you can get it
as close as you want to one but you can
get uh so using the structure theorem
that I mentioned and combined with fkg
inequality uh you can say that this goes
up to you can make it as close as you
want to want by setting a small number
of coordinates when your function is
increasing
and let me close with two open problems
one is actually from fruit cuts paper
which is what I couldn't is that Lemma
which I can generalize basically is that
suppose your function is increasing and
you're actually in this p-bias setting
then
the structure theorem that frika shows
is that your function is close but to a
to an increasing function which is
generated by small minimal elements or
for people in computer science area
maybe they're more comfortable by saying
that it's it's very close to a dnf with
only positive literals which all classes
are of constant size
so you can approximate it with that
uh
so for example now in the non being
non-bipartized in the graph case you can
look at this things of containing odd
cycles and then up to some constant then
you get better and better approximations
and well now that uh I have this
structure theorem to prove this you need
to show that every
case to the Junta which is increasing is
close to a dnf with bound the size of
classes so it looks like a very
combinatorial problem we don't deal with
influences anymore it's just you know
you have the case to the Junta actually
you know it's you have your function
comes from these constraints and you
want to
get rid of all these cases of large
constraints and get something get an
approximation with a dnf
and the other
conjecture is
that in the setting 0 1 to the N which
actually captures the whole General case
we're working with separable
probability spaces
if your function is increasing now you
can find a small set of coordinates such
as either setting them to one will give
you something close to one or setting
them to zero will give you something
close to zero you can't just have well
one of them is not true
you you have to have this kind of
dichotomy
um
why it's not the why so why not both of
them
it's not correct because
the end yeah so for example yeah when p
is one over n we look at that case
uh so the way it relates to I mean it
doesn't relate but it seems that you
have now this structure and you should
be able to answer such things knowing
that you you know you understand the
structure of the function but I can't do
it so
the previous slide you showed it for
discrete setting yes yeah so if your
function is zero one from zero one to
the n and p is small then you get this
case actually for that you need P to be
smaller less than half
and then its p is very large larger than
one half then you can get this one but
this kind of it's kind of combine should
combine both in some ways
thank you
foreign
Yes actually in my proof fat doesn't yes
no I use just four games inequality
which uses that yeah yeah
no it doesn't is but it uses something
similar so what so
uh so this is square function inequality
that
um I'm going to write it I think
you look at this sums of atmosphere
and then that the lq norm of disk is
comparable to alphino
X
some of this for Q larger than
yeah but and there is dependency here so
this is for S at most K and we get some
constant here C to the
okay probably
yes yeah it's very similar but
so if I had this here I would get yeah
it's more General
structure in here
yeah yeah yeah exactly
no because it's some kind of automatic
technique uh
there's no
it just realized on the two points
I mean the proof is again you just prove
it on one that Dimension and then tensor
right
the last question
is there a maybe one can also
characterize or not even character I
just get the analog even of the organ
result for function which are the no
which are not in a noise sensitive so
either the influence is small the the
the most of the Fourier coefficients are
in the low levels the low levels so it's
likely certainly a more general area but
wasn't the first step just
truncating the function and looking only
the low level okay
I mean the only place where you use the
no but for games serum uses
that is total influences now
so yeah so essentially maybe you can
extend bougainsiram to the case where
the side of the condition total
insurance is small yeah the the most of
the Fourier coefficient is the low level
which is more General and then maybe
there are more the condition should be
modified so what happens in the just
uniform the uniform case you for example
get the weighted so there is a theorem
that the every function
were most of the Fourier coefficient is
concentrated on the low level has a
positive correlation with the weighted
majority yeah
so it need to be a weighted majority it
only weighs a positive correlation yes
and this includes also
majority
then do you get a structure theorem that
is just get correlation okay just get
the the first week yeah
okay
yeah that's interesting maybe in this
case you can get a correlation with some
structure
but I don't know
yes
in this country
so specialized
okay